[Music]
in blame the Jews News that's
anti-semitic all submitted by TFT I
thanks for the invite
thank God is Friday that's ki jaya
thanks is a washington lawmaker is
apologizing after blaming the
Rothschilds for bad weather I don't know
what to make out of that
what is that for room we're the
Rothschild again yeah they are a big
banking family okay big-time banking
family they had anything to do with the
weather so they're saying they can pay
Zeus they are the monopolies Rothschilds
are a European business family descended
from Mayer Amschel Rothschild an 18th
century Jewish banker yeah so that's
that's who the Rothschilds are so this
councilman he named Trey on white senior
he made some comments on a facebook
video and I will show it to you now I
just started snoring out of nowhere this
morning
y'all better pay attention to this
climate control man it's climbing
manipulation and DC keep talking about
we're resilient city and that's a model
based off the Rothschilds controlling
the climate to create natural disasters
they can pay for it all the cities might
be careful that's a councilman ting mr.
white how these talk when he's when he's
at work mr. Walter white my mind then
you talk like that sounded like a taxi
driver just like that casually yeah like
a blue-collar worker
taxi driver because he was in a car taxi
driver I knew he was gonna look exactly
like that I could tell he was black from
his voice I could tell you I Qatar's
wear a suit the suit gave it away in his
voice yep so what's the big deal well it
turned into the big deal cuz it was any
somatic comment he does anything Jewish
though he just said the Rothschilds
that's like me saying like the [ __ ]
Kwan's yeah the [ __ ] Kwan's are
destroying our our [ __ ] sunny
California weather and they're like oh
you're your anti-chinese Joe what the
[ __ ] so it's like there have been these
wild and any somatic conspiracy theories
accusing that family of secretly
orchestrating world events and
supposedly controlling the climate to
destroy certain cities so they can like
I feel like that's so personal to that
family it's not Jewish
I hate the Jews because they made the
Rothschilds which control the weather
we beat anti-trump isn't being
anti-white yeah yeah I think anything
could be made racist sexist or
anti-semitic depending on who the butt
of the joke or the butt of the comment
is it's like not personal anymore but
things can be said directed at just the
person I know Jewish people and none of
them know the Rothschilds it's true
that's for a hundred percent to none of
the Jewish people I know not to control
the weather either so how did this
I dislike get out of proportion and get
blown up like this well a lot of people
were upset and he ended up issuing an
apology on his Twitter Wow well as a
politician though he knows being a
politician they'd [ __ ] believe in
conspiracy theories and all that that's
the stupid [ __ ] you can't do that true
yeah so he tweeted out I really do
apologize I work very closely with the
Jewish community and never want to
offend anyone especially with an
anti-semitic remarks and then he
attached a note with further apologizing
the rothschilds though they have a bad
rep because the daddy Rothschild he sent
all of his sons to pretty much take over
the banking in a lot of different
countries in Europe and and he had like
a quote it was like I don't give a [ __ ]
who rules the area or who the king is if
you control the nation's money supply
you control that nation
so because of quotes like that I guess a
lot of people think that their
diabolical family that wants to control
all the countries and [ __ ] and that's
where the conspiracy started that's just
a dumbed down version just having Jewish
heritage now it's being tied to that
culture or whatever see that's that's
the anti-semitic
and there's another racist stereotypes
unlike people linking it and then be
like you're at a semantic cuz you're
talking about the Rothschilds that's
more anti-semitic than someone saying
something about a specific person yeah I
agree but that's where it all came from
and I don't know nothing cuz I don't
know any Rothschilds and I don't know
any Jewish people that know Rothschild
so I think that's just [ __ ] if we're
the Rothschilds because I'm not really
good at history where they in the same
era as like the oil tycoons and stuff
when they had to make the laws about
monopolies like when they had to out lob
I don't know
I think the Rothschilds were in Europe
and an oil tycoons are here and I don't
know if they were friends okay I like to
thank all the diabolic financial it's so
easy to make like super powerful rich
people into like these monsters yeah I
think that money brings out who you
truly are like if
into a large sum of money you either do
a lot of philanthropic stuff with it and
help people and make charities and
that's like just where you want to put
your money or you get this power hunger
that's like what else can I own I think
that part of you is always a part of you
and then money just brought it out of
you or you could start something really
big and then someone else could come in
infiltrate it [ __ ] it up yeah well I'm
saying there's the people in between
that are self-aware of that very
specific thing and they do philanthropic
stuff just for a good people to cover it
and the greediness you can get away with
they're like freak freak stuff on the
side how do you ever know cuz you don't
know these people you only know what the
media covers of them yeah like our
perception of them is like you know
pretty much CNN reporting [ __ ] or
whatever or like people writing stories
about them that's why I think that it
isn't that far-fetched and I'm not
saying I believe this but it isn't that
far-fetched to me that there's a shadow
government because like what do you do
like when you have so much money like
billions and billions of billions like
you'll never have to where your family
never has to worry once you're at that
level of life like operating on that
level and you may be even born into it
you've never experienced like what
regular people have to do like you're in
this completely different field of life
now it becomes like competition and
games of like you know just these big
rich people playing each other as a game
of throne like manipulating the public
to like win some weird billionaire game
you know I don't think it's not
far-fetched like when you have we see it
on a smaller level with YouTube and
entertainment exactly how people lie to
their fans [ __ ] with them and then try
to stir up drama or like behind the
scenes like they're like best friends
and they pretend that they're having
issues so then the fans could get like
entertained and then and they pick side
pick sides
it grows their [ __ ] and I think that's
what they like with politics like I just
feel like they try to get people to pick
sides yeah they can really like sit down
with someone that is a Republican and is
a Democrat a lot of them they want the
same thing but they just have different
ways of
Solutions and they have different people
telling them that the other side's a
monster they're a slave to their group
yeah like they have no identity
individual identity right they have to
believe whatever the tribe says I think
the real monsters are the ones making
you believe that your neighbour is a
monster I mean think about Hillary and
Trump have been friends for over thirty
plus years even more you could see
photos of them together since like the
80s or the 70s even just old-school
photos of so many events so many
gatherings they're in real close
proximity like hanging out mm-hmm
their daughters hang out how can you
think that they they don't like each
other or like yeah that's why there's
this other level of people that have
like billions of dollars that they're
living in a different universe and then
they just like manipulate what the
public sees and fuels and stuff and I
think it's like it's like a game with
their board the other board right like
cube piercing brat Reese oh is that
where all the billionaires just bet on
people yeah it's like Hunger Games but
less death I don't know if you guys had
all that much money do you think you
would just be so bored or it's like
let's see what I completely know I want
to buy an island and fill it with
kittens and want to I'd hire like a
pancake chef and I would eat banana
pancakes all day
no pancake lady oh yeah you don't like
french toast or waffles that's all right
I'll eat it yeah of poor taste
excuse me mm-hmm how would you spend
your money Bart I would get a french
toast man on my island man no it's not
gonna be an island two competing
breakfast islands it's gonna be a land
beach it's still connected to other
parts like a forest and all that stuff
I'm gonna go on Harlan you're nuts
it's a land beat with the French toast
everybody sounds really boring yeah it
does sound boring what is that when the
man that makes you walls I don't want
that french toast
gross her tourism campaign sounds a
little
[Laughter]
Airport is closed like all the fun
activities like jet skis parasailing
skydiving scuba not better than Hawaii I
don't want to eat a kitten for [ __ ]
minute me I didn't know about this there
was an employee he's fired the control
your own Island people no I'm not I'm
not going I didn't have Vegas [ __ ]
it was just like any every cuisine of
the world I'd build a build of Vegas
yeah build a bigger fire it sounds just
like Vegas
Judith Vegas was on a beach that would
suck that would be dope Macau is kind of
like that but then I don't even take
advantage of their beaches there
Macau it's weird Hong Kong oh how about
Singapore don't they have a cookie they
do this marina bay sands but Asia's on
earth they're not even there locals
aren't even allowed to go into the
casino all that shit's hella fun and
creative yeah but they also have morale
so they don't have to you know yeah they
don't have casinos you need the perfect
mix you need people that know how to
have fun on a rally they play the
pachinko machine I need the perfect
blend you need the Vegas on the beach I
feel like there is dude I feel like in
Southeast Asia there is a but it's not
popular like there is I feel like there
is the Lapine's has a casino but also
porous I don't want to see sadness the
island that I'm picturing in my head is
like just for us and like everything's
free oh that's the difference there yeah
a real world does not open up for
tourism for other people everything's
free someone's got to pay for it the one
who won the lotto has to pay for that
yeah that's like a 1 cent or not really
want things Anthes so if we're not there
the workers are bored they're just in
their [ __ ] unification
are the workers looking at name time to
say like Barbara and it says like
Indonesia or something yeah cool that
would be so boring yeah hey cuz they're
just we're only there for like the
summer for like two weeks or something
whatever kind of like cruise yeah but we
were not there what are the staff doing
what are we doing that we're not there
fall in I don't know I'm just worried
about the staff like it's so boring they
signed up for it I'm not cool with
slavery guys it's that slavery paying
them you think we're those billions of
billions of dollars and we're not paying
our staff you know come on we are not
heartless monsters we just like kittens
and pancakes I'm just gonna pay them
really good and eating beauty begins
[Music]